c'est une petite course masque une
petite course à skis
les deux chefs d'equipe que je vais
nommer sont isabelle morini-bosc idem
rejoint d'isabelle et j'ai raté
géraldine maillet vous allez devoir
faire une course à ce que les quatre sur
les mêmes filles d'accord c'est très
simple il va falloir partir de là faire
le tour du plomb et revenir on a essayé
on répète c'est très très dur très dur
les séries c'est très simple joli si
chacun trois personnes avec vous allez-y
la première personne dont je sais aussi
disséqué fils gilles verdez vous êtes
avec isabelle va déjà l'équipe commence
bien remarquez c'est kelly d'un becquet
dit elle en arbitre t'inquiète pas tant
mieux benjamin bratt jeanneret castaldi
je rassemblais déjà cette équipe
toualy c'est quelqu'un maxime maxime
gainey highway dix mois c'est une équipe
de bras cassés ou total on est sportif
catalan y aller seul avec vous je te
vends que des bons skieurs
non mais enfin vous choisissez 6e au 4e
essai qui est contre la grèce qu'ils là
il respire bel outil réservé à râler un
bernard montiel avec eux à l équipe est
pas bien on dit la lie à quelque chose
et un jeu rapide
oui j'en dis nagato coût qui reste chéri
un gâteau prouvant sur quels joueurs
allez c'est parti à bientôt les séries
c'est ensemble c'est philippe candeloro
qui est avec nous on va faire comme dans
le film la deuxième étoile silva bloqués
à la mi mai
il a commenté tu vas compote de quoi qui
va commenter à courtrai ce que vous
après est-ce qu'on apprête à 13 fois
commande aujourd'hui dans les studios de
boulogne à deux chiffres une chute c'est
une catastrophe syrie il ya deux chutes
qui vient de se faire de l'est de
londres a dû porter le tout il n'ya pas
de réparer des rebelles touaregs ou bien
on tiendra jusqu'au jolie coordonner ces
dames soyez coordonnées allez on reçoit
comme auchan ont rechaussé alors que
l'équipe du petit chaperon rouge
chaussée est complètement désorienté a
dream
l'équipe au pape à londres est
légèrement en avance allait dépêcher ou
des fichiers ou quand un chronomètre
tout l enfant
pour les 5 à 10 années
c'est fini